ein astronomie team hat ein relikt aus
der zeit der entstehung des weltalls
gefunden eine gaswolke die
ausschließlich aus der materie besteht
die sich kurz nach dem urknall gebildet
hat dort sind keine sterne und keine
planeten entstanden und somit gibt es
dort nichts anderes als wasserstoff und
helium warum wieso weshalb blick zum
science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierende songs
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
das ist wirklich faszinierend und wie
kann so etwas aufgespürt werden ein
überbleibsel aus uralten zeiten dass
sich seitdem nicht verändert hat dazu
muss man eines wissen das periodensystem
eine riesige tabelle mit 94 natürlich
vorkommenden elementen und noch weiteren
elementen die nur künstlich hergestellt
werden können nach dem urknall bilden
sich allerdings nur zwei elemente
nämlich die mit den ordnungszahlen eins
und zwei im periodensystem wasserstoff
und helium wasserstoff besteht aus einem
proton und einem elektron und helium
besteht meistens aus zwei protonen zwei
neutronen und zwar elektron also die
einfachsten atomkerne sie entstanden in
den ersten minuten nach dem urknall
nicht mehr und nicht weniger dann war
erstmal schluss und erst als die
gaswolken danzig millionen jahre später
zu sternen und galaxien zusammenstürzten
entstanden die weiteren elemente durch
kernfusion in diesen stern rückschluss
wenn man eine gaswolke ausschließlich
aus wasserstoff und helium bestehen
finden würde wäre sie während des
urknalls entstanden und seitdem nicht
mehr verändert worden doch wie spürt man
eine solche wolke auf dabei hilft wie
schon bei sternen die spektralanalyse
jedes element absorbiert nämlich licht
unterschiedlicher wellenlängen
unterschiedlich stark so lässt sich zum
beispiel sehr genau bestimmen aus
welchen elementen ein stern besteht wenn
man jetzt eine galaxie hat die durch
eine gaswolke hin durchleuchtet dann
kann man das spektrum dieser gaswolke
analysieren und dann würden in diesem
fall also unser gaswolke nur helium und
wasserstoff licht absorbieren und genau
das macht jetzt die gefundene gaswolke
nichts hat sie verunreinigt in ihr
findet man nur die ersten beiden
elemente des periodensystems wasserstoff
und helium jedenfalls vor 12,3
milliarden jahren so lange
das licht von ihr zu uns nämlich
unterwegs wir sehen sie so wie sie 1,5
milliarden jahre nach dem urknall
ausgesehen hat was inzwischen aus ihr
geworden ist das werden wir erst in zwei
drei milliarden jahren erfahren denn das
ist das paradoxe an unserer sichtweise
auf das weltall
wir sehen es quasi zeitlich verzerrt
alles was ein lichtjahr entfernt ist
sehen wir auch so wie es ein jahr zuvor
ausgesehen hat und so weiter
umso weiter etwas weg ist desto mehr
schauen wir in seine vergangenheit
theoretisch würde das bedeuten dass wenn
sich ein raumschiff mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit auf uns zu bewegen
würde wie es an jedem punkt seiner reise
gleichzeitig sehen würden nur dass wir
an den verschiedenen positionen die
insassen in einem anderen alter sehen
würden wenn die astronauten astronauten
hier auf der erde angekommen 50 jahre
alt wären würden wir sie gleichzeitig in
20 lichtjahren entfernung in einem alter
von 30 jahren sehen und so weiter und so
fort wir sehen also quasi ein extrem
verzerrtes universum allerdings liegt
der verdacht nahe dass die gaswolke auch
heute noch so existiert denn wenn sie so
lange nicht in sich zusammengestürzt ist
und galaxien und sterne und planeten
gebildet hat dann ist es auch
wahrscheinlich dass sie auch heute noch
so existiert wenn sich an dieser
situation etwas ändert werden sie es auf
jeden fall nicht hier erfahren und auch
nicht auf dem englischen kanal
denn bis dahin wird es unsere spezies
voraussichtlich nicht mehr gehen und
wenn wir auch milliarden jahre in die
vergangenheit sehen können für die
zukunft geht das leider nicht und ich
vermute mal sehr stark dass klicks um in
ein paar milliarden jahre nicht mehr
geben wird um allerdings sicher zu gehen
sollte die klicks auf abonnieren und vor
allem auch bei whatsapp mit dabei sein
denn da erfahrt ihr früher von
bedeutenden ereignissen dafür hier
klicken und hier geht es weiter mit
nanotechnologien wie wir die
grundbausteine unserer welt verändern
können bei doktor watson unbedingt
abonnieren hammer kanal bis dann bleibt
dran